hey guys Pete here here I'm going to do
a video where I'm going to talk about
Audrey and I'm going to tell you upfront
I don't really have any answers but it
was sort of like this thing I was
thinking about it earlier I started
reading some stuff and a couple of
things hit me right at the same time as
I came across other things you know what
I mean it was kind of a weird chain
where you know I was thinking about
something and I would see something and
I don't know I thought it was
interesting so we saw another Audrey
seem in part 15 but overall it was more
of the same we didn't see any progress
there and I said in my top moments video
that it's like she stopped I don't
really know what's making her stuck but
it's clear that she can't leave the room
she wants to leave the room but she
doesn't want to go and it's a really
bizarre kind of plotline for a character
that was so important in the original
series now I've been reading all the
different theories that people have and
I haven't been a hundred percent into
any of them like last week I was going
to do a video about the different
theories and I just came away after
reading them all is just like I don't
really like any of these like they all
work they're all well thought out and
everything but I just don't like the way
it fits into the return of Twin Peaks at
all it just doesn't feel right so today
I did that again I was talking to a
friend that was sort of frustrated after
the last episode and they didn't like
the Audrey scene and they wanted to I
think the words where I wanted to slap
her in the face for not putting on her
coat and I guess I get that like I've
been kind of fascinated with it so it
hasn't drove me insane but it's one of
those things that when I think about it
after the fact it's like what the hell
is going on there the most plausible
explanation is that she's in the coma
but it's really not that plausible 25
years is a long time and I had looked
into this before and it's definitely
possible to be in a coma that long so
super rare and there's a lot of problems
with it because of if that is the case
how is she finding out about all these
characters and what I was thinking about
the most this morning when I was
thinking about it was the whole
roadhouse connection and I ran across
the boy that's one of the
I ran across that was interesting so
we'll look at that but as far as factual
evidence that we know there isn't much
after season two it was sort of a
cliffhanger of what happened as far as
the bank explosion was concerned in the
secret history of Twin Peaks we found
out that she survived that but no real
details she was in a coma and her father
Ben was by her side but we don't hear
anything about her state in between that
and the present they didn't say that she
recovered completely or she didn't
recover completely and this led to the
idea that she might still be in a coma
after all those years we also heard from
doc Hayward this season in part seven
when he said that she was indeed in a
coma and that evil coot may have visited
her at least that's what he thought so
that led to the theory that Richard
Horne might be a product of evil coop
impregnating Audrey in the latest
episode it seemed that there may be a
fatherly connection because we did find
out Audrey was Richard horns mother and
it doesn't really give up too much so
when I was looking into today I ran
across this theory and I don't
necessarily think it's right but I think
it's interesting to think about reddit
user coop the poop scoop which is that
the only common going to say that
because it's a tongue twister of sorts
so yeah this guy he wrote up a theory
that he thinks he figured out where
Audrey was and posted it yesterday main
idea here is that she strapped in would
like Josie was at the end of her life
and like the log lady's husband was so
as I'm saying like I don't necessarily
know this is true but it kind of hurt
being in a supernatural place kind of
fits better for me than her being in a
hospital bed for 25 years so some of the
things he points out of her actually
being dead rather than in a coma are
that on the phone doc Hayward says that
she was in a coma when Richard Horn
talks about seeing agent Cooper in a
picture he says that
long past tense to his mother when evil
coupe asked who is your mother the
present tense makes Richard pause before
answering he goes on to point out that
no one ever mentions Audrey and he
thinks that's because she's trapped in
wood somewhere and I don't know that
that's a really strong clue necessarily
because he goes on to say if she was in
a coma people would be going to visit
her but we don't really see that much of
the intimate details of people's lives
in this story so I don't know that we
can really take too much away from that
but either way his thoughts are that
she's trapped in the walls of the Great
Northern or she's trapped in a table at
the Roadhouse now the evidence for the
Great Northern would be that the noise
that they heard if she had been in a
coma for a really long time then maybe
they would have taken her home and she
eventually passed there which let her
move into the wood at the Great Northern
and all that stuff okay that I could
paya get into that except for the dying
at home part like it seems a little bit
like complicated in a way like how would
they explain that later and what time we
have left but you know whatever it's
like I said I don't know that this is
necessarily the right theory but it
would kind of tie up those little things
like the noise and everything else but
then if you look at that that actually
takes away the connection to the
Roadhouse because most of what happens
in that this there we find out is
related to her and good bad or
indifferent those scenes seem to be tied
into something especially like I said
after the last episode like there's no
way that it's just random filler it
could be extremely unimportant to the
end of the story as far as Cooper's
journey goes but it's definitely
important for some reason because it's a
recurring plot line and it's one that
they haven't ended yet so then if you go
to that end in she is a table in the
Roadhouse the whole idea of how she got
into that is pretty convoluted so yeah
could she be trapped in wood well it's
historically something that we've seen
happen in the show we don't really know
that mark
his husband was trapped in the log but
we do know that something was going on
with that log like she had a connection
whether you want to call it psychic or
something along those lines like she
knew about stuff and she carried around
that log which that's where she said
that information came from my log has
something to tell you things like that
so there is definitely a chance that she
could be in wood but I think that
there's also an equal chance that she
could just be trapped in a way that's
similar to what we've seen with Laura
Palmer we thought Laura Palmer enter the
lodge after she died or the Red Room at
least in 25 years later we saw some form
of her that said that she's dead but yet
she lives that talked to agent Cooper
before he left there and we don't really
know much else about Laura
from her own point of view we know that
something happened with the fireman or
the giant where he created this orb but
we don't really know anything else
beyond that and we've never actually
seen what the experience of being in the
Red Room is like for anybody in a
convincing way outside of Cooper so
Audrey being stuck could be something
similar to that so the last thing that I
came across as I was thinking about that
and I was thinking about the Roadhouse
basically because there was that video
that came out where they synced together
the scene with the girl crawling across
the floor and screaming and duggie coupe
going crawling to the outlet and they
kind of sync up so it's interesting but
so I was thinking about that some more
and we did catch another thing there
chuck was someone that we heard Audrey
talk about and then we found out that
Renee's husband his name Chuck and he's
the one that was punching James in the
face so right after that I was looking
at Twitter and I saw this post I guess
you would call it it was a I guess it
was liked by someone that I follow
because it's not a person that I had
followed before and they were talking
about that same thing about the boots
how the characters all connect back to
Audrey and the fact that Audrey's trying
to get to the Roadhouse they mentioned
Chuck showing up and that we've heard a
lot about Billy there
Audrey says she had a dream about him so
yeah I don't know I really don't know
what's going on with Audrey I'd be
interested to hear what you guys think I
think it's safe to say that she's not
actually in a marriage with Charlie and
that's the house and everything is
occurring in real time she may in fact
be married to Charlie but it's equally
as likely that she's dead and she's
somewhere else in between the real world
and Twin Peaks and many others the
farther out of essentially pat monica
bellucci stream and Gordon storyline
that somehow she is the dreamer and
everything we've seen is not actually
real but I don't think I don't think
anybody wants that to be the case I
think it'll be a little bit more
interesting that's sort of why I don't
think the coma thing or the therapy
thing or the you know institutions any
of those that's why there's not exactly
right in my mind so let me know what you
guys think give the video a like if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you have not already follow
me on Twitter and hit me up over there
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon